I'll write it and we'll do it live we'll
do it live all right I mean we should
cross everyone and we are live with our
latest episode of the conversation and
with me this month is our host here and
one of our hosts here at the daily where
Michael knows we'll be taking what can I
say your name right no no I should have
done all of those things you were doing
can we do a redo huh can't do it Noah
live with me is Michael Knowles you know
famous author of that New York Times
best-selling blink book who will be
taking your questions alive for this
entire hour all right remember as always
our conversation is streaming for
everyone to watch but only subscribers
get to ask the questions I feel like we
needed a t-shirt in our Amazon Prime
daily wire store that's like an outline
of me saying only subscribers get to ask
the questions because I have to say that
in my mom voice every single time we do
an episode of the conversation guys so
how do you become a subscriber head on
over to daily wire.com be sure to create
a login give us all of your wonderful
money get a leftist ears tumblr if you
do the 99 bucks um for the year it's
like you're practically making money
okay if you read the tumblr you get this
guy andrew Clavin matt walsh ben shapiro
tons of great options there so click on
the link in our video description if you
want to ask a question and to become a
daily wire subscriber and be sure to
tune in for next month's episode it's
gonna be much better because it features
our editor-in-chief ben shapiro
wait a second just just saying so i feel
like a year ago when we were doing we've
been doing these conversations for
almost a year and a half by the way can
you believe that actually maybe even
almost two years that's a lot of
conversing it's a lot of conversing with
our amazing subscribers that somehow
keep your show on the air it's amazing
but back then you said that you are
working on another book but this time it
will have words in it yeah
TBD oh no it's a it is actually coming
along I still don't want to talk about
it because the last time I had a book
idea I said I submitted this whole
proposal for this book idea and the
proposal they didn't like it they wanted
me to change all these things and then
another guy came out with the exact same
book like three months later and it's a
very good book so I'm telling nobody
about what this book is but it's very
fun I'm really enjoying it you
we'll probably not be surprised to learn
that that has happened to a couple
friends of mine as well that's very
frustrating yeah never you never get
this when you do a blank book by the way
because other people there have been a
lot of blank books there's everything
men know about women and wit and wisdom
of the German people a lot of very good
ones reasons to vote for Democrats X
after 15 was another one oh my god I
sold a lot of copies uh-huh alrighty so
we have our first question I don't this
is from who Anthony wants to know what
do you think will happen to the pro-life
movement if SCOTUS reaffirms roe v wade
with Alabama's challenge to abortion
then we'll keep going on we'll keep on
keepin on this isn't the first time that
this has happened roe v wade was decided
in 1973 it invented a fictitious right
to abortion it didn't even say where it
found the right to abortion in the
Constitution the opinion said well maybe
it's in the Fourteenth Amendment maybe
it's in the ninth amendment it doesn't
matter there's a right to an abortion in
there which is ironic because if the
right to an abortion is in the
Fourteenth Amendment then the people who
wrote the 14th amendment were unaware of
that the people who adopted the 14th
amendment were unaware of that at the
time of the ratification of the of the
14th amendment by wire hangers and
back-alleys didn't exist
shockingly it did so it the first laws
to deal with abortion happened in about
1821 the 14th amendment comes in 40
years later at the at the time there
were many states and municipalities that
had laws against abortion and actually
at the time of roe v wade at least 21
states and municipalities had those same
laws on the books and yet the Supreme
Court invents the right to abortion then
20 years later you get Planned
Parenthood v Casey this is where the
Court reaffirmed the right to an
abortion it puts certain restrictions on
it I guess in the intervening 20 years
the Constitution magically magically
grew new restrictions on abortion but
whatever now 20-30 years later if this
comes up hopefully we can overturn Roe
vs. Wade
I actually spoke to Antonin Scalia about
this topic before he died and I said you
know conservatives we accept precedent
there's a concept in the law story
decisis which is that we give some
deference to
so how do you square your belief in
precedent with overturning Roe versus
Wade and what he said is that some
rulings are so egregious that they must
be overturned Dred Scott would be an
example of this perfectly ruling that
black people cannot be American citizens
you can't gradually incrementally change
that you got to overturn it Roe versus
Wade the same thing you can't coherently
say we we're gonna protect babies at 28
weeks but we're gonna kill them at 24
weeks it doesn't make any sense
you have to overturn it and if the court
doesn't have the guts to do it this time
guess what we're gonna do we're going to
keep on passing laws we're gonna keep on
fighting public opinion is moving in our
direction and we'll get them the next
time you know it's interesting because I
think the argument that you're seeing
from many on the left is that oh no
Donald Trump has stacked the courts and
they're gonna overturn roe v-- wade
honestly I don't know that as a
pro-lifer that I can count on justice
Cavanaugh or Chief Justice Roberts to
make the pro-life Pro Constitution
decision in this case well this is what
they said in Planned Parenthood v Casey
it was 1992 so that you just had a
decade of the Reagan administration the
Bush administration stacking the courts
and what happened three justices
appointed by Republicans Anthony Kennedy
David Souter Sandra Day O'Connor all
voted to uphold the fictional right to
abortion this happens a lot the Supreme
Court justices disappoint their
presidents often and can we really count
on John Roberts
I don't seems like we can can we count
on Cavanaugh jury's still out but I'm
worried all right irune says dear dr.
Kofi Fay I've been a victim of
affirmative action often due to being an
indian-american
any advice on how we conservatives can
subvert discriminatory policies in the
university and workplace well actually
speaking of the Supreme Court this
decision probably is going to be handled
by them pretty soon because you've got
this this case coming up about
discrimination against asian students at
harvard so affirmative action what also
was upheld
thanks to Sandra Day O'Connor and other
justices and what the court said at that
time the last time they really dealt
with this is eventually affirmative
action will not be necessary eventually
we can phase it out the question is now
can we phase it out because affirmative
maybe it's really helpful to black
students applying to Harvard but you
can't help some students without hurting
other students like Asians and Indian
Americans and Indians right so if it's
going to hurt those students they have a
real discrimination case and
unfortunately a lot of these questions
now are being decided by the Supreme
Court and the reason they're being
decided by the Supreme Court is because
the Supreme Court has taken on that
power the legislature has not wanted to
do its job it's brought these questions
to the court and unfortunately the court
has invented fictional rights over the
years and when you're basing your
decisions on those precedents you have
to invent more fictional rights or you
have to read new new interpretations
into these fictional rights and so I'm
hoping that this Court which for all of
their flaws has been much more seriously
minded has been much more respectful of
the Constitution in recent years
hopefully this Court will at least issue
some legal and constitutional clarity
and get rid of some of these issues that
have caused so much trouble over the
last several decades all right Jonathan
says hi Michael I really enjoy your show
I think Jonathan maybe needs some
hearing aids anyway he says I'm a
Protestant and I'm wondering from the
Catholic perspective what is the purpose
of praying to Mary and to other Saints
well it's a very good question I get
this question a lot from Protestant
friends of mine I will answer with a
question to you do you ever ask your
friends to pray for you give or say hey
Johnny my wife is in the hospital can
you pray for us do you ever ask your
church you say let's all pray for each
other if you're doing that then you're
asking for intercessory prayer right
you're asking for them to pray to the
Lord our God this is exactly what
Catholics do and and or Eastern Orthodox
when we pray to Mary we are asking Mary
to pray for us to the Lord our God we're
saying I mean that the the prayer the
Hail Mary prayer is directly from
Scripture you say hail Mary full of
grace the Lord is with thee blessed art
thou amongst women and blessed is the
fruit of thy womb Jesus Holy Mary Mother
of God pray for us sinners now and at
the hour of our death so we're asking
Mary to pray for us why do we ask the
Saints to pray for us again the same
reason you asked Joe down the street to
pray for you we know that the Saints are
in heaven but that is the that is what a
saint
by definition is somebody who is in
heaven and we see in the book of
Revelation we see that the the Saints
are holding pots of prayers as they are
before God
now if the Saints are holding pots of
prayers what are those prayers for are
those prayers for the other Saints no
the other Saints already have it pretty
good they've already they're already in
heaven those are prayers for us those of
us who are not Saints yet you've seen
the book of Maccabees you you have
people praying for the dead so you have
an intercessory prayer there as well
praying for the hope of those who have
already died but are not yet in heaven
or not yet in paradise so that's why if
Joe down the street is worthy enough to
pray for me certainly the mother of God
and the saints in heaven are worthy to
pray for me as well
alright Veronica says my khipu is that a
new nickname I love it that's okay my
khipu i am on the university professor
track but I'm really losing hope and
ready to burn the system should I change
course stay in it to be a voice of
reason go to a leftie school please help
this is such a tough question I was like
a three-in-one but I get all of the I
think the expression and the emotion I
get I totally get where you're coming
from I have a lot of friends now who are
trying to become professors who are
early in their academic careers who are
getting PhDs and they all have this
problem they say the university has been
hollowed out from the inside so you have
two options you can either keep your
head down go along with all the awful
pronouns all the awful revisionism all
the awful political correctness get
tenure and then be open about your views
first of all it very difficult to do
that on the best of circumstances how
long do you have to wait for tenure you
for most people their entire life they
don't get it but for some people could
be twenty years thirty years so you can
either do that or you can say gosh the
universities are really falling apart
even professors with tenure have been
chased out of universities I know some
of them and one of the alternatives for
them or these institutes you know the
Elm Institute in New Haven is one there
are a lot of think tanks that do summer
programs I got a lot Hoover
Claremont Hoover yeah all of these that
are associated with universities but
necessary or necessarily only employing
professors that might be the smarter
option you you can
you can do your work there you can
interact with students some of the the
classical education I got such as I got
it was really thanks to summer programs
and these research institutes that I
would do for two months and they would
teach me more about our civilization
than for years at an elite University so
maybe that's one way that you can have
your cake and eat it too you can have
your beliefs you can be open about what
you think you can publish what you want
to publish and you can also have a
career in the Academy I think
increasingly it's very difficult for
conservatives to have a career in the
Academy in large part not because of the
other leftist professors but because of
the administrators the administration of
Stanford smear'd Andrew Clavin yesterday
I based on nothing but said
conservatives are not welcome there the
administration of UMKC and Missouri
smeared me is some kind of bigot based
on nothing said that conservatives more
or less are not welcome there I don't
want even Christian universities that
you thought we're conservative do that
too ben shapiro
even got with a gonzaga GCU LMU and
that's a test and simply christian or
conservative anniversa tea so I don't
want to rain on your parade I just want
you to have a good career and so when
you look realistically at this you
should consider other options other than
the traditional academic route because
even if you weren't a conservative I
think because the universities have
become so rotted out from the inside
because we're at the height of an
education bubble that is going to burst
even if you were a leftist I would say
maybe consider some alternatives that in
which you might be more successful all
right Rob says hello your honor do you
believe the abortion controversy is an
indication of a larger return to
religion it perhaps I mean it is the
case that the big divide among abortion
is not between men and women men and
women have basically the same views
about abortion it's it's not even
strictly a question of Republican or
Democrat the the biggest predictor is
religiosity and it's not because the
science is not on the side of the
religious people science is very clear
the word conception if by definition
means that's when life begins it's
because we have a view if you are
religious of human life is intrinsically
worthwhile
and as intrinsically valuable we have a
view of the moral law is objectively
true and not just some illusion as as
moral relativists and many on the
secular Left would say so there is a
religious component to it and I I think
maybe we're having a return to religion
as a culture because we couldn't get
more secular where we've gone so far in
the secular direction you've got a whole
generation of people Millennials Gen Z
who have been raised more or less
without religion even the ones who have
been raised with religion have this
Softsoap saccharine sentimental religion
that's not based in in real orthodoxy
and I think what people want when
they're asking serious questions or
serious answers they want orthodoxy CS
Lewis said if you look for truth you
might find comfort in the end if you
look for comfort you'll find neither
truth nor comfort only soft soap and
wishful thinking to begin and in the end
despair I think the reason Jordan
Peterson is so popular right now is he's
telling people look there's a meaning in
the world there is a metaphysical
meaning in the world and this leads
people to a lot of religious questions
and ultimately I think to an Orthodox
faith there's certainly coinciding but I
don't know if it's the religion leading
people back to pro-life I think it's
people asking basic questions if the
babies are not a baby what is it if it's
if it's wrong to kill a baby why is it
wrong why would it be right I think it's
actually those questions ultimately
leading people back to a religious faith
or a quasi religious faith I think also
you're seeing a thank God for the advent
of modern medicine and the level of
detail and the fact that the point of
viability now is so young it can be 20
weeks can be 20 weeks I mean at 24 weeks
should they tell you that there's a 60%
chance at 28 it jumps up to like 90 yeah
31 weeks having forbid I were to go into
labor right now she would baby have to
be in NICU for a couple of days you're
right it is incredible that modern
medicine and I think the majority I mean
it's upwards of 70% of even Millennials
in the country recognize that a portion
past 20 weeks just doesn't make any
sense
and now because of those medical science
not even because of religious
perspectives right
because of technological advancements
there was a video that just came out
today Missouri just outlawed abortion
after eight weeks there is a video of a
little baby in the womb at eight weeks
and you know it doesn't look exactly
like you or me it's clearly a baby it's
got its fingers it's got its toes it's
got its little eyes and it's a little
mouth beating heart beating yes it's got
a beating heart certainly but it's had a
beating heart for at least excuse me two
weeks but you can tell it's a baby you
can see that and you can't unsee that
yeah all right Veronica wants to know is
there any way that we can convert or cut
out squishy conservatives from our group
oh yes there have been well there are
there's a range of squishes I mean
squishes on different topics so what you
might think is a squish on one topic I
might think is it squish on another you
right right so but even even the
squishiness is a little interesting I
mean everyone's talking about the
abortion debate right now I would never
call Pat Robertson a squish I mean he's
a guy who referred to feminism as an
anti family socialist movement that
teaches women to leave their husbands
destroy capitalism practice witchcraft
and become lesbians he's a pretty
hardcore guy and he said this abortion
law is too extreme
Tommy Lauren over at Fox News said this
abortion law is too extreme I don't like
it
people are going a little squishy on
this issue because some think as a
matter of prudence that this is not
going to succeed at the Supreme Court
and it's harder to argue for a more anti
abortion at the first eight weeks than
it is at the at the back eight weeks and
some of them are actually don't care
about abortion at all and they wish we
would drop this issue as pro-life
conservatives fight the fight fight the
fight I mean look it's all good talk you
can talk a good pro-life game when it
comes down to the laws are you gonna
support the laws are you gonna defend
life or are you gonna say well I didn't
really mean that I want everybody in the
popular culture to like me what is it I
mean this this issue in particular is
separating the pro-life wheat from the
pro-life chaff and that's not to say
that we don't need a big tent we don't
want people from different perspectives
to support a conservative agenda
and the Republican Party in so much as
they are conservative don't put the cart
before the horse don't compromise on
important issues if you're not gonna
back these laws which which are enacting
what the pro-life movement has been
talking about for decades then you're
just a big fake you're a total phony so
do it you know I mean put your money
where your mouth is or or don't but
don't don't compromise on an important
issue and on a principle in the hope of
being this a little bit more popular
among people who aren't going to support
you anyway I think that's totally
putting the cart before the horse all
right Timothy says Michael from the
block lots of new nicknames for you
today I like it
alright have you seen the new Tolkien
movie I think he means a it's supposed
to be like the romantic eyes
autobiography by a biopic of Toki yes
and if so what are your thoughts about
it I've heard that it fails to represent
how important faith was to him in his
life I haven't seen the movie so I can't
comment on it I've read all the same
reviews of it that you have j.r.r
tolkien was probably what who's that
comedian who always talks about food Oh
Jim Gaffigan Jim Gaffigan he was the
sort of Catholic yeah it's like 500
birther by the way I believe his wife is
not him he jokes that he takes naps
uh-huh right
he junior Tolkien was the sort of
Catholic who Gaffigan would probably
refer to as a Shiite Catholic I mean he
was like pretty hardcore he would he
would jokingly refer to CS Lewis as his
heretic friend because Lewis was an
Anglican the the Catholic faith was
central and essential to JRR Tolkien's
life if the movie isn't almost entirely
about that then it's probably failed to
to portray Tolkien's life and some of
the reviews have said it barely mentions
it at all really yeah again I can't
comment on it cuz I haven't seen it but
if that's the case then probably the
film is not worth very much as a
biographical piece so I often have this
conversation with friends I'm Ivan I'm a
non-denominational person you're devout
Catholic practicing I'm gonna keep on
practicing until I get it right you guys
believe a lot of practice that's what I
need yeah
and we often talk amongst family and
friends of how don't make and drew
Andrew Klavan says this a lot
don't make Christian movies make movies
yeah
don't make Christian music just make
good music and I wish that something
like Hollywood would understand that you
can still make a good buy a biopic about
someone without it seeming too religious
you know because religion was so
important to him his friendships his
marriage his writing right it was it was
a huge part of that
yeah there's allegories like everywhere
in his writing the Lord of the Rings how
can they how can they not include that
like to just gloss over it really I
think loses the richness of a beautiful
story of course I mean it would be make
a movie about Jerry Falwell but don't
talk about Christianity make a movie
about the Pope but don't talk about
Christianity okay I mean I don't know
what's the movie gonna be about that I
you know you you've got a Hollywood and
the left generally prioritized their
narrative right they want their in the
JFK movie they talk they don't talk
about how a communist killed the
president which is actually what
happened they come up with all these
conspiracies of Republicans in Texas or
whatever if the facts don't fit their
narrative they go with the narrative but
at a certain point it just becomes
ridiculous and it diminishes the value
of the story they're trying to tell
Samuel says regarding school choice are
you not worried that private schools
will increase their cost of tuition like
colleges have when government began to
subsidize them not particularly I mean
we there have been school choice
experiments throughout the rest of the
world Sweden Sweden has near-perfect
school choice and it's increased the
quality of education rather than
decreased there are secondary effects to
any sort of massive government policy
that you are going to see but again this
is why school choice it's not really a
federal policy I mean this is why
education is run by the states and
should certainly be run by the states
and and it does increase competition
obviously it's being funded in some part
by the government but you are getting
all of these schools to compete against
each other for those federal dollars so
I think rather than lowering standards
or increasing
everywhere that we've tried it you've
seen you've you've seen the quality of
the education increased dramatically
just to use one example in the state of
Florida under Jeb Bush Florida had
ranked number 48th in the nation's bat
it was awful they instituted a ton of
school choice thanks to Betsy DeVos and
to Jeb Bush and they rose up to be
within the top ten in the country in
some cases within the top five that's
the only statistic I need to say we need
to try this and all the other
laboratories of democracy around the
country I think the point about
competition is so true and in addition
to that it's not just them competing for
federal dollars it's parents having that
money via vouchers for example or a tax
incentive tax write-off that can then
empower them to make the best decision
for them in their child total I mean
they're even I heard Secretary of
Education Betsy DeVos talking about
education savings accounts you know you
have a health savings account by not an
education why not an education savings
account what that would do is allow you
to use maybe you want to spend some
money on one course at a community
college then you want to take one course
at a Catholic school then you want to
take one course at a trade school and
and if you don't use all of that money
it can roll over if you don't use it by
the time you finish high school it can
go to toward college these are the sort
of educational reforms that you're
really only seeing on the right and and
what is the left offering it's more of
the same they want to they the guy who
was running for governor
Andrew Gilliam governor of Florida he
just got beaten out by Ron DeSantis he
promised to undo all of those education
reforms send these kids right back down
to number 48 and when you dig into the
statistics when you dig into the actual
election numbers you'll see Ron DeSantis
doubled the support for a Republican
among black women
yep than anyone else why because he was
saying I'll allow your children to have
a chance at an education this is
something that I think that even in
leftist socialist California polls
incredibly well across the board because
you have moms is it specifically
minority single mothers in this state
that of course they want what's best for
their child and if the government can
give them the freedom to choose the best
educational future for their
and help him find a way out why wouldn't
they take it I don't know why
Republicans don't run on that in states
like California yeah well when they do
run on it even in left-wing states they
tend to do a lot better then then when
they don't so I think it's a totally
winning issue and I'm not afraid of it
at all let's go for it all right I don't
know how to say this I guess freedom
tuned Danny wants to know if you've seen
freedom tunes parody of been great I
don't think I've seen that yeah it's
great it's a Ben's whole family imagined
through the lens of freedom tunes and
they all just look I will tell you I
mean I know Ben for years and his family
completely accurate right I mean you
know that you've seen it it's completely
even down to the little baby just like
googoo gaga
Thanks don't care about your feelings
it's just completely spot-on baby that
speaks like five languages everyone in
that family this is this is where you
know Ben and I often joke that our
oldest's his will take over the world
and mine will run the PR for it because
like genetics matter yeah well everyone
in the Shapiro household is just a
genius all of the siblings take and fast
mind moving a mile a minute kids it's
not fair it's you know it's great we're
feeding into the conspiracy theory that
they control the world but that's true
but only to Shapiro's disappear as
knowles
why don't republicans have any khones to
get things done like you said they're
often disappointments to conservatives
what's wrong are they really not
conservatives at heart also are your
glasses for more Vieux Carre parker
various you're not only in astute
observer of politics you're in astute
observer of
aesthetics as well fashion they are I
actually I was on Fox and Friends one
morning and Steve Doocy comes out he's
got is like a zillion dollar wardrobe on
and he comes up he goes hey knowles
Warby Parker 100 bucks aren't they great
no man that's perfect
on to your actual question about
Republicans being squishes yeah it's
very frustrating the reason that this
happens to a lot of Republicans is
because their currency the thing they
want the thing that gives them value is
votes it's not ideological purity
it's not accomplishing the agenda they
set out to accomplish it's not making
conservatives happy its votes it's
getting votes and people who are elected
to high offices are really really really
good at getting votes and to get votes
you don't need to be right you just have
to be popular and so there's that there
is a huge incentive among Republicans to
do that some Republicans hate
conservatives I've met a number of them
they they feel much more comfortable
with Democrats and left-wingers than
they do with conservatives they like
John McCain called conservatives wacko
Birds remember that the nuts lunatics
that sort of thing they would feel much
better at a cocktail party in DC with
Democrats even though the Democrats want
to raise taxes and they want to lower
taxes ultimately they feel much more
comfortable with them than with
conservatives it's like they're
embarrassed of us the Conservatives are
good enough to get them elected but then
they don't want to talk to them it's so
oh it's I want to hang out with my new
cool friends who are all Democrats I
don't want to be seen with you weird
loser conservatives that's very
frustrating and the way that
conservatives fight that is to it's just
to not take it you know I mean on these
big issues like the abortion issue which
we're all dealing with all week in all
of these states across the country say
the truth say the truth fearlessly
hold people in your own party to account
and if they go squishy throw them out
throw them out of office I mean you
don't it does us no good to have a
republican in name only in the
legislature or in an executive role
don't you feel like that's kind of a
rhino is less likely now though I think
partly since the Tea Party movement but
also in the age of Trump that you're not
getting people that are as squishy yeah
and the beauty of our system is that
they are supposed to or typically
represent their constituency well this
is something that Trump really has
changed for the better which is that
before Donald Trump people would go on
stage typical politicians even
politicians that I like and they would
say something and you would know that it
wasn't true
and you but okay you promise something
that you know it's never going to come
to me I know that but you know that it
means something else right and so here's
an example every politician of both
parties would say we need to move our
embassy in Israel to Jerusalem that was
back when both parties liked Israel now
the Democrats don't like Israel so they
stop saying that right but the
Republicans kept saying that but we
still thought there's no way that anyone
doesn't so Trump he's kind of new to the
political scene he comes up he says yeah
we're gonna move our embassy in Israel
to Jerusalem so he gets an office what
does he do he moves the embassy in
Isreal to Jerusalem and everyone loses
their minds Republicans as well as
you're not supposed to do that so if we
everybody for it's been the official
policy of the United States since 1995
everybody was just saying it now I'd do
it and you're all mad at me say yeah
you're supposed to say it but you're not
supposed to do it I think what Trump has
shown us is voters will reward
authenticity even you know Donald Trump
has a checkered past
in his personal life to put it mildly
but he's pretty authentic about it he
doesn't really cover it up we it's been
in the tabloids since the 1980s and he
and he's kept more of his promises than
any president in my lifetime for all of
his craziness and I think that's that
has opened up the window for discussion
and shown conservatives hey you can say
what you mean you can then do what you
said that you would do and voters will
reward you for that that's that's a
great change and I hope that continues
after Trump alrighty
please remember we're almost halfway
through so if you want to ask Michael a
question you need to head over daily
wire comm and make sure that you're a
subscriber because our conversation is
live for everyone to watch we're
streaming on like YouTube Facebook daily
we're calm right now allograph but only
subscribers get to ask the questions
click on the link in our video
description to ask questions or sign up
and be sure to tune in for next month's
episode featuring New York Times number
one best-selling author of the right
side of history Ben Shapiro featuring
another number one best-selling author
oh you turn your number you number one
though number one baby on the Times list
oh no The Times threw me out the times I
don't even want to talk about the times
and I hear you want
[Laughter]
alright Jacob says MB what chances do
you think there are of an overturning of
Rho V wait if any I think it's a nonzero
chance I think there is a chance of
overturning roe v wade I think it's the
best chance we've had since roe v wade
I'm not holding my breath I think that
the court under John Roberts is
interested in maintaining its integrity
mm-hmm which mean which ironically means
not having any integrity right the
Supreme Court watches the election
returns and John Roberts has shown
himself to be a highly political Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court I'm not
holding my breath but I have hope I'm
not optimistic I'm not pessimistic I
have hope
they say the difference between a
Scottish optimist or the Scottish
pessimist Scottish pessimist says things
can't get any worse
Scottish optimist says things can get
worse I promise you that's optimism and
pessimism or two sides of the same coin
I have hope even if they don't overturn
roe v wade we're not going anywhere
they thought that they ended the
abortion discussion in 1973 America is
much more pro-life now than it was in
1973 so fine do your worst I hope the
supreme court has integrity and
overturns
the worst decision in American history
Roe vs. Wade and if they don't alright
see you next time guys that optimism
versus pessimism argument is something
that a Dennis Prager and Ben Shapiro
often have dude do that yeah yeah yeah
it's funny I actually have a third view
on optimism and pessimism because
they're both just feelings right their
optimism and pessimism say forget the
circumstances I'm only going to have
this this feeling all the time but III
mean I think real real hope is the
knowledge that things are gonna keep
getting worse things are gonna keep just
getting worse and worse and worse
so you're pessimistic optimist in a
sense yeah because I know eager I think
says he's an optimistic pessimist yeah I
mean I the reason the reason I feel that
way is I know that eventually this this
whole world is going to stop spinning
the Sun is gonna go out I'm gonna turn
to worm food but hey my save your lives
I can have open that alrighty
CJ says I struggle with the
do you have making a woman carry a rape
baby to term because in this case her
rights have been violated versus in a
regular pregnancy where the parents
should just take responsibility what are
your thoughts this is obviously the hard
case right well if a woman is less than
1% of cases in the case of rape it's
probably less than half of 1% and in
rape incest or threat to the life of the
mother all three of those combined or
less than 1% so I I do think the left
wingers who are using this example oh
yeah I think they're being very
disingenuous here but let's let's
consider that actual case in in the case
of rape yeah that's a horrible crime the
crime is the rape and so their way to
get justice for that rape is to punish
the rapist now Matt Walsh made this
argument he said you know rapists love
abortion because abortion gets rid of
the evidence of the crime I'm an Alabama
coincidentally which passed this
abortion law has some of the toughest
rape laws in the country I'm perfectly
fine with capital punishment for rape if
I were king I would institute it I'm not
King and we around the country we do
have tough laws on rape in in that case
however
the babies the baby the babies the the
logic of pro-life is that a baby as a
baby and you can't kill babies who are
innocent
now this extends even to that point
although I will make a just a prudential
observation here if somebody is raped
they go and they you know go to the
hospital and they deal with all of that
collect evidence that sort of thing they
can take plan B I'm not advocating the
use of Plan B but however I'm there are
drugs that are not necessarily abortive
fashion so they can act as abortive
fashions that people can take in that
case that will make surgical abortion
completely unnecessary you may have your
own thoughts on Plan B my faith tells me
Plan B's is not morally licit however in
even in that the hard case of rape which
accounts for less than half of 1% of
abortions there are many alternatives to
surge
abortion and I think the people who are
who are using the case of rape to to
make the point that we actually should
kill a million babies of year
statistically none of whom are conceived
via rape I think they are being totally
disingenuous and the final point on this
of course is that hard cases make bad
law the these very difficult rare cases
make for bad law because what they're
trying to argue is that because of one
possible reaction to a very rare
occurrence therefore we need to kill a
million babies a year that logic doesn't
hold up all right nick has a question he
wants to know if the abortion debate is
more about how to define human life and
personhood do you believe it's possible
to have a conversation on the national
level with something this complex at the
moment it's very difficult to have that
conversation because our moral discourse
has been totally degraded and it's been
degraded by creeping materialism and
relativism among the populations so now
we can't even talk about things like
virtue or purity or God you get accused
of being an old fogey you yeah will you
get a religious man trying to tell me
what to do with my body
exactly and people who say it's your
truth and it's my truth and you can't
tell me and I that someone about the
abortion debate tweeted out they said
you can't legislate how other people
live that is the definition of Abba law
the law tells other people how to live
but we can't have that discussion and
it's no plot even tells other people
what to do with their children you're
right online all day is there's a reason
you know DSS and CPS and truancy
officers and law enforcement exists
exact because if you're you know what
parent you lose you lose your kid
exactly and so the I mean it is no
coincidence that as we've lost the
ability to have moral discourse in this
country abortion has become more rampant
we if you're asking about when human
life begins we know we know for a fact
when human life begins it doesn't happen
before fertilization a sperm cell as a
sperm cell that's 23 chromosomes you
leave it be it's gonna be a sperm cell
and that's gonna die
an egg has 23 chromosomes if you leave
it be it's gonna be an egg and it's
gonna die when you combine the two and
the sperm fertilizes the egg you get a
new human being with 46 chromosomes that
will grow and become just as
recognizable as you or me or our
grandparents are that becomes a new
separate individual human being that's
what human life begins we know it's a
life from the moment of conception it
meets every scientific characteristic of
life we know it's human because it's not
a dog and it's not a kitten then it's
not a giraffe it's a human life that is
when that begins and if you want to have
then the the more philosophical or
theological conversation of personhood
or insolvent we at least have to we have
to first agree on what human life is and
unfortunately the pro-abortion cratis is
unwilling to do or unable to do even
that but I think common sense is
spreading around this country I mean
Georgia Alabama Missouri Louisiana
you've got all of these laws challenging
abortion directly Ernest Hemingway
described bankruptcy as it happens
gradually then suddenly and the pro-life
movement has happened gradually now it's
happening suddenly and I think maybe
people are are waking up if not to moral
discourse at least to the the total
insufficiency of the way we talk about
these issues now all right this is a
funny question I don't think it's PC to
say this but I guess I'm just gonna go
ahead and say it anyway okay Veronica
wants to know if you have a perspective
on whether or not gingers have souls oh
it's very clear that they do not have
souls this has been proven time and time
again obviously they're known like
redheaded Saints the I wonder well st.
Patrick is actually often depicted as
redheaded because he was from Ireland
but he wasn't for my Rene I thought he
was British and he went to Ireland a
minister he's Roman he's a Roman citizen
everything is it like I picture him is
just like a big Italian guy with a big
nose and beard you know yeah I don't
know if there are any redheaded Saints I
mean well that's a real question for the
theologians and the historians but it is
a fact of natural law I think I'm pretty
sure this was proof by Thomas Aquinas
that redheads do not in fact have souls
what about strawberry blonde Oh
strawberry blonde
okay because I have one of those home
intelliwhite you're lucky she's done so
Michael says you don't have a salt 20
months no all right Rob says dear mr.
know-it-alls oh I like what he did there
you see that I see that right there
uh-huh do you agree with Ben regarding
the fact that Alabama went too far with
their abortion prohibition no no I don't
I think it's a terrific law I totally
support it but I don't by the way I
don't think Ben is making the argument
that it's too far I think it's gonna be
overturned by the court yeah I think
he's making a political argument or an
argument from prudence so I I do respect
the argument but I don't agree with it I
think fight the fight the time is now
this is the pro-life moment and and
coincidentally we happen to be right all
right
irune wants to know dr. Kofi Fei what do
you think about judicial review more
generally do the courts have the power
to make nationwide injunctions on
abortion marriage I mean we could even
go into like some of the EPA decisions
that they've made all right the Hobby
Lobby case for that were the EPA
decisions that they don't make I mean
one unfortunately one of the one of the
great hopes I have for justice Kavanagh
is that he will upend the administrative
state because of a very awful Supreme
Court decision in in the Chevron case
Chevron deference the idea that courts
will defer to the administrative
agencies to make their own rules and to
adjudicate their own rules which is I've
been though isn't hopeful that he's
gonna do that though well we're talking
about this less he's a little more
pessimistic than I am but I mean sure I
know one can predict the future we don't
know how it's going to go yeah but the
the two questions that were asked or
different questions and one is what do
you think of judicial review I think
it's been the principle since the
earliest days of the country since the
Marshall Court that that the court has
the ability and the right to interpret
the Constitution and invalidate statutes
that that violate the Constitution so
I'm fine with judicial review but the
court does not have a right to invent a
right to abortion the court does not
have the right to redefine marriage as
Anthony Kennedy did in the obergefell
case those are those are very different
questions and the court has utterly
overstepped its bounds
and even in recent years I mean thanks
to guys like Anthony Kennedy and I wish
that the court would step back and and
realize that the United States was meant
to govern herself and not be governed by
nine robed lawyers who have appointed
themselves the benevolent betters for
the whole country but hope springs
eternal in the human breast I don't
think that's really gonna happen
actually again when I saw Scalia before
he died we we said what about states
rights
what about returning power to the people
and he said you're barking up the wrong
tree I'm a Fed you've given us all of
your power you gave up direct election
of senators you've given the feds all
your power so even if I were
intellectually inclined to support
states rights I have no political reason
to do so and and that's a problem of
seating power to the federal government
to the courts for for over a century all
right David says Michael what cigars and
whiskey would you recommend for a newbie
Oh I mean you're asking me to pick
between my children how could I possibly
good cigar look you can get a good cigar
for under ten bucks well you know yeah
you don't need to spend 30 or 40 bucks
on a cigar you can you can spend a lot
more than that but there are great
cigars that you can get for 10 bucks
anything by Don Peppino any my father
cigars are great oliva cigars are really
good for beginners a bunch of other
lines that are they're really good but
those those two are kind of cheap and
good ways to start and then for whiskey
can't be Johnnie Walker Black as
Christopher Hitchens explained the
preferred whiskey of the Iraqi Baath
Party the Palestine Liberation
Organization part of the Saudi royal
family the Libyan dictatorship before
they were ousted some of the worst
people on earth also Winston Churchill
Johnnie Walker Black Label fabulous way
to begin and not too expensive alrighty
good to know
it's a whiskey kind of like wine that
there's wine for all different sorts of
palates like as their whiskey are their
cigars from all different palates and
occasion yeah there is so some like
Johnny Black is really good for cigars
it's actually a great match for cigars
others
when I go out with Drew he insists on
Macallan twelve that's also a good one
to begin with yeah he and the god-king
really like Macallan oh yeah and the
god-king actually loves Irish whiskey
probably the most you know that's super
aged Irish whiskey we spend about the
same amount of on whiskey per year
Jeremy and I it's just the Jeremy buys
one very expensive bottle and I buy
dozens of cheap bottles but yeah for all
their there are some for all different
occasions but yeah I would recommend Don
fifteen and Johnny black is a good way
to to introduce yourself to the freshmen
levels oh yeah I mean they're there's so
much you know - these are the great
pleasures of life they make life really
enjoyable and what there's a great poem
about it tobacco is a dirty weed I like
it it satisfies no normal need and like
it it makes you thin it makes you lean
it takes the hair right off your bean
it's the worst damn stuff I've ever seen
I like it your ability to remember
random like totally useless
I mean yep I wish I had your memory
thanks a lot like your memorization
still a lifetime I was like all 28 years
so true or false
I feel like whisky can be enjoyed
without a cigar but can a cigar be
enjoyed without a drink yes
but it's much more difficult okay you
can enjoy whisky alright you can enjoy a
cigar with a coca-cola you can enjoy a
cigar with even a glass of water it's a
little more especially if you haven't
spam you know I've smoked cigars now for
15 14 years or something like that I'm
like 12 years old so that's a lot but if
you're not used to it it's a little
[ __ ] you might you might want a
little bit drink kind of balances yeah
where is for Scotch I mean Scotch goes
great you know nice first thing in the
morning open your eyes get you ready for
a working day at the day a little bit of
the coffee little Ben they left us to
use tumblr that's right that way when
water tastes I'm kidding
all right next question Noel's explain
all of these extra books that you
Catholics have oh well I I wrote a lot
of them myself so I'd say know what
you're referring to is that the the
Catholic Bible includes more books than
various Protestant
believe it or not I've read them yeah
that's pretty good to read them though I
will just correct you though a little
bit on the extra books the Catholic
Church existed before the Protestant
churches so
was a question of removing books from
the Bible but I you know anybody who
tells you that he can interpret all the
books of the Bible is selling you a bill
of Lies I mean especially when people
tell you they can interpret revelation
oh man oh you're talking you brought up
revelation earlier I was like mmhmm what
are you going to go on it give me your
insight to the apocalypse I recommend
reading them I mean I recommend even if
you're a Protestant or any denomination
that you are you you really should know
the history of the church and not just a
Cliff's Notes history
you should really delve into it I mean
Martin Luther knew the history of this
church John Calvin knew the history of
this church is Bingley knew the history
of this church so you should know that
too and you shouldn't just settle for
you know some series of ideologies that
you've been given you know from from the
CliffsNotes version you should really
delve into it you should know the hymns
you should read the Church Fathers you
should read the books of the Bible that
various people like Martin Luther
decided they want to take out you should
know why they wanted to take those books
of the Bible out you should know why
certain lines of the Bible were changed
in the 16th or 17th century when you
should know those reasons and if you you
should defend those reasons if it's if
it's part of your faith and if you are
convinced by it and if not then maybe
look at a different denomination you
should know the difference between the
Eastern Orthodox and the Catholic Church
and the Anglican in all of those I mean
that regardless of what tradition you
come from even within the term of
Christianity and learning about all of
the others will inform your faith I mean
you you have nothing to lose but
ignorance I really would love to see you
and Allie Stuckey have a conversation
about faith we do it every time she
comes to town but affair I want to see
an honors education because she's
obviously a Calvinist and she's a real
Calvinist I mean she really bars for
Calvinists yeah and then like you being
a practicing Catholic yeah it's it's I
know it's great because she's such a
bulldog - and her that's a lot of I
always love doing it we'll have to get
her on the show or something that would
be fun yeah all right Anthony says who
do you believe will be the first
Democrat to drop out of the presidential
race keep in mind the forgettable ones
like Whovian gastro Kirsten
Gillibrand forget Castro and Gillibrand
what about jay Inslee you remember he
he's the guy whose logo looks like a
cd-rom from the 1990s Bill DeBlasio my
former Bolshevik mayor from New York
just got into the race I mean he's not
polling Eric's wall well is not showing
up in polls right now and which is
really sad for me because Eric's wall
well said I am you so I am Eric small
well which means yours to lose the demo
but you will too I guess so we'll all of
you okay I mean it once you hit the
debate it's it's gonna thin out pretty
quickly and it's not gonna be just one
person dropping yeah you're gonna lose a
number of people we're now up to 23
candidates in this race and if you're
not registering in polls you're not
going to get onto the debate stage if
you're not on the debate stage you're
not gonna raise any money whatsoever and
you're gonna have to get out then but I
think I mean obviously Inslee
Hickenlooper is probably not going
anywhere there's so many that you just
don't even remember or running I feel
like I mean de Blasio actually had
people booing him outside of GMA today
people were standing outside of GMA
booing him people think he's such a
crappy job with New York I wonder if
he's gonna be one of the first people
out because he's gonna think that he has
the name recognition and support there I
really don't know he doesn't and and I
will say it's not an ideological thing
New Yorkers hate Bill DeBlasio yeah the
Democrats really wanted to play so much
a show called the Mindy project Mindy
Kaling who I feel like even though she's
a liberal we'd be BFFs in real life I'm
just throwing that out Mindy if you're
nearby like we can be friend watches
this show all the time totally sure she
watches the Michael Nolt show yeah she
would rip on de Blasio in that show all
the time yep and she's like a liberal
feminine that's wrong you workers hate
him yeah they don't like him yeah he's
probably not going very far I kind of I
guess I was asked this to the great
students at Turning Point USA at
Augustana I heard that we've been saying
it wrong by the way gnorga Stannah
Augustana is how you're supposed to say
it they I was like sorry guys I think
it's gonna be clubbin Shar oh I forgot
she was a thank you I kind of like her
her she's tough
her townhomes I've been horrible that
yeah she's a bad candidate she's I mean
she did the Jeb Bush move she did the
please clap move that's never a good one
I do like that she throws office
furniture at her staffers I mean that's
pretty tough but yeah she's probably not
long for this race
Aric like derek zoolander but combines
good name dear swarthy lad
oh god can you think of a greater power
disparity than an abortion doctor and a
child still in the room if not is this
just a great evil by the standards of
the left of course we never talk about
how oppressed the little baby in the
womb is we know you know we talk about
the marginalized we talk about the the
UH the the disadvantaged the people who
don't have any privilege is anybody more
vulnerable disadvantaged marginalized
and oppressed than an unborn baby Matt
Walsh took to calling them undocumented
infants who are trying to cross over the
wall of the birth canal in search of a
better life the left probably should use
those terms there's a great essay that
was just published actually in the Yale
Daily News it was by an undergraduate
guy who said a more ssin is not mercy
and he said we talked about how we don't
want to bring unloved babies into the
world and they're gonna grow up in
poverty and have suffering it's better
to kill them he said I'm one of those
babies I never knew my father
my mother was a complete mess I grew up
on couches and I grew up on the street
and in motels I was in foster care I
dealt with abuse
I went hungry a lot I had a bad
upbringing and all my foster care
brothers and sisters had bad upbringing
and they were abused physically sexually
emotionally really awful stuff and we're
glad were alive because you endure that
suffering and you also get the joys of
life and all that suffering makes joy
that much sweeter and all that suffering
makes the joy that you can give to other
people that much sweeter and and the
people in the people make the argument
all the kids gonna be born poor is gonna
be he's gonna suffer he's gonna be
unloved you're making the case that you
should eliminate poverty by killing poor
people you're making the case that you
can erase the poor of this realm there's
a there's an it's it's the most heinous
argument than anybody seriously makes in
politics I encourage you to read this
it's called abortion is not mercy it's
in the Yale Daily News
I wish the left would read those stories
because they talk out of one side of
their mouth and they say these are the
people we've got to help and then out of
the other side they say we're gonna help
them by killing them they've got the
the knife right behind their backs BJ
says I recently had a discussion with a
liberal regarding morality
she believes that morality is all
relative sounds a lot like AOC and it
can be determined by society what is the
most convincing argument for moral
absolutes morality by definition is
objective that's why there's no such
thing as morality if morality is
relative or subjective if morality were
subjective
it would just be preferences right it
would be preferences that you and I
agree to and then we create the social
construction called morality but then if
we agree that it's wrong to murder
somebody it's not objectively wrong
right we've just subjectively sort of
agreed that we would prefer if we all
pretend that it's bad to murder somebody
and this is refuted by the way by all of
history and anthropology right people
all over the world in all eras have
intuited naturally intuited a very
similar idea of an objective morality
but even if that were not the case if we
just all said okay it's not objectively
true then what you're really saying is
there is no such thing as morality and
and if you behave as though there is
you're a gullible fool I mean you're
you're you're not making a lot of sense
and if you follow that idea to its
logical conclusion there really is no
morality it's just a total illusion that
a bunch of people who believe a fairy
tale have convinced themselves up you
should read the Marquis de Sade the guy
that we get the word sadism from he
wrote a book which is pornography and
philosophy it's called 120 days of Sodom
and it shows you a world without
objective morality where you would
actually follow your own desires because
in a world without objective morality
your pain is not more important than my
pleasure and if that is the case then
you get sadists you get the behaviors of
psychopaths but we're not a psychopathic
society at least not just yet we have a
conscience we have a moral intuition we
know that there is an objective moral
law and we know just about what it is
that's objectively true and the people
who pretend that there isn't I noticed
they very rarely live as though there is
not an objective moral law all right
Rob says can assist man feel like a
lesbian trapped in a man's body a day of
my life
every day of my life I do thank you for
understanding my suffering and not
erasing the suffering that I a lesbian
trapped inside a sis male body face
every day
so I read a horrific story but it's it
was so brave new world to me about a
person that was transitioning that
identified his male the government had
male male on his ID but it's at her and
it was a pregnant man according to this
ap story that ended up dying during a
steel stillbirth because the medical the
nurses and the doctors looked at the
medical records that showed male and
we're testing for things that were not a
pregnancy right gone wrong right yeah
but you never hear those stories in the
mainstream media do you it was it's
horrifying
cuz men can't be pregnant right okay I
mean now people pretend they can there's
no such thing as transitioning there you
can mutilate your body or shoot yourself
with hormones or pretend that you're a
different sex there is no actual such
thing as transitioning but now the old
the old surgery that makes you more
resemble the other sex used to be called
gender reassignment surgery now do you
know what it's called gender
confirmation surgery which is the
opposite now if you call a man who
thinks he's a woman if you refer to him
as a man you're accused of misgendering
uh-huh the only person misgendering is
the person who pretends that the man is
really a woman so what if I don't have
the gender confirmation surgery how can
I confirm that I'm actually a woman how
do I know that you're well well but
these days I know it's very confusing I
I can't think about I could be the first
pregnant man remember that the first
pregnant man and he was on with Barbara
Walters on 60 minutes we're 60 minutes
spread that's right the second pregnant
man oh there he is
irune doctor cough fa my family are
Trump supporters but our souring to the
president because he didn't build the
wall how common do you think this is and
could Trump lose in 2020 due to not
building the wall absolutely he could he
he lost his biggest supporter and
Coulter
I mean Ann Coulter said build the wall
come on Donald and he didn't do it he's
got to build the wall he says that he's
doing it he's talking a good game I know
it's very hard to do it I sympathize I
feel bad for do you think it's really
it's not his fault that the wall hasn't
been built well it's his it's his fault
in so much as the buck stops with the
president I think it's practically
impossible to build a wall I don't think
it's for lack of trying and make Mexico
pay for it or just the first part well
we you know look money is fungible and
we and Mexico like we are the dominant
partner in our trade relationship with
Mexico so we can squeeze some money out
of them no question but the and I think
it's look it's obviously in his interest
to build the wall I think he wants to he
would win reelection instantly if he did
it it's very difficult but yeah yeah
that's difficult being president of
stuff they have said there's some
immigration announcements that will be
coming out of the White House knock on
wood
so we'll see this is our last question
can you believe it gosh
thank God we made it honey a whole hour
okay last question comes from Matthew
but this is a ode to your new Twitter
handle formers I got is it I got it I go
thank former zygote former zygote
Michael knows me I'm looking to get
involved in pro-life causes and I live
in Maine my wife has told me she wants
to go to a rally do you know of any base
in New England this summer I don't know
of any off the top of my head but the
pro-life movement is everywhere so I'm
there are great places to check out for
resources on this you might already know
them but live action is a great one
that's Lila roses outfit they do great
work all of the Catholic websites are
big on pro-life relevant radio is
another great one Patrick Madrid who
does a terrific show Patrick often these
guys are talking about it so you can go
to their resources and find them susan b
anthony list is another one i mean there
were so many human coalition human
coalition i mean so i that would be the
first place that i would start because
they post a lot of information about how
to get involved with pro-life so i would
definitely start there because you like
me or a former zygote and when people
use they use this word zygote zygote
means the baby right when he's been
formed right when he's conceived and
it's the kind of word that you learn in
seventh grade biology class
and people who use it with a straight
face in conversation later on you know
that they they never intellectually
progressed beyond seventh grade biology
class so I think we all just need to
point out I am a former zygote you are a
former Zygo okay and all of those
abortion supporters the curious thing
about them I just I've noticed this just
like Ronald Reagan noticed it they've
all already been born
strange coincidence huh absolutely thank
you
for this month's episode of the
conversation this flew by thank God for
all of us thanks to all of our awesome
subscribers who how do you subscribe
well head on over daily we're calm so
next month you can not only watch us
because we do stream live everywhere for
free but if you want to ask Ben Shapiro
a question you have to become a
subscriber go do that right now we got a
fun exciting backstage coming up with a
surprise guest there's lots of cool
stuff behind the paywall for our amazing
subscribers thank you for joining us
everyone I'm Alicia Krause and I'll see
you next time
[Music]